i'm in the house i grew up with in the
middle of fife scotland there's no
rational or logical explanation
or any reasonable idea for me to ever
believe that i'd ever get to perform
on coded so every time i do i'm like
they've made the same mistake again this
is excellent let's keep it tight
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome the
very funny
daniel sloss
[Music]
first time i heard about you was at the
fringe and i didn't get to see you that
year but i was contacted by your agent
and you were going to potentially be
traveling
to the us and so i without ever
having met you helped set up a bunch of
gigs for you
i don't know how much you know about
this and then you actually had to cancel
you couldn't come over
i don't know much of that i think i
butchered like the ice house and a bunch
of other spots
why did i count and some scheduling
issue i believe
i was never offended by it but the funny
thing is in order to see you
i could just drive to pasadena i had to
get on a plane fly to edinburgh
see you at the fringe and not only get
to edinboro like edinboro
is you know it's a long trip but staying
in the center of town
most of the comedy shows are at this
other venue
different venues that are pretty close
to each other like there's the pleasants
and there's the under valley and there's
the
hub yeah they're all in the city yeah
yeah yeah you
choose to be another 25 minutes away of
a walk
away from those venues yeah and land and
then i've got to
walk 25 minutes out of town to come see
you
you got to watch it
[Laughter]
getting there was totally worth the trip
it was one of the best shows i'd seen
that year and i that night we were like
let's just
figure out a set and do it explain
how you put your set together and what
you sent me did i just walk around a
hotel room and record it to you there
yeah oh god like a sociopath
older material i've really struggled to
watch myself any old
shows of mine because i don't know i
just think i'm crap now
then just by comparison so i watched
this earlier and
i managed to get most of my cringing out
for comics who haven't done tv before
saying dress slightly better
you want to wear a suit but slightly
better than what you would wear on stage
this is slightly better than both this
it's slightly better than what i wear on
stage
are hello all doing well most of us
fairly disappointed that a child just
walked on stage
i didn't even like home alone
it was the cut-off point for that joke
working right i've been doing that joke
since i was 17 years old
and then this i'm 23. i was really
stretching the childhood
the last drops of the milk out of that
one just going okay
i guess i still you look look young
there
[Music]
my mom's had four kids you can tell that
she loves us all the same
but after the first two she kind of
stopped caring she'll always go back she
was blessed with me
then she was gifted with my sister then
she had my brother
and she'll always remember the day that
she was diagnosed with the other one
we need to stop right there i'm
so excited i put that joke in there
specifically the joke that's about
happening i put it in there specifically
because i knew that you were going to
take it out that
it's a joke that i put in every single
set for the years because i know
especially the uk people want to edit
your set just so they feel that you're
better yourself so you put in something
that you know is not going to get in
uh they take out they feel like they've
done their job and then they leave the
rest of the set alone
that is purely the reason i put that
joke into sets and you were the first
person
when i said through this set you were
like yeah i'll fight for it and i was
like
there's no way
this is gonna be on the show when you
said i could genuinely and
watching it is watching this clip is my
favorite the
joy on my face the sheer joy
and it's a genuine laugh and it's such a
genuine reaction of a mischievous child
going
i can't believe they let me do it we
were all intentional though
uh which is good my mom's uh has a very
healthy eyelid to contraception which is
great
because her sister is anti-abortion
which is a cruel nickname but she's had
five
i'm as surprised as you want that they
let me
[Applause]
i know i'm shocked um but
that's the moment when i properly
relaxed that was just
i can't i still can't believe i get i
got to tell that joke
on national television in america
that was great that was fantastic
daniel ladies and gentlemen really nice
job
the comment from everyone was the exact
same which is when you watch gordon
coming up to me
he's it seems like he's genuinely
surprised that i was good
like he's like oh my god it's good the
child was funny
and then it's just me star struck and
bumbling through words but like
i had a lot of fun thanks for having me
one of the kind of ongoing discussions
in the comments section
uh was your level of attractiveness
is it really no is it yeah yeah
yeah i mean there's one that says right
here it says he is probably one of the
hottest comedians i've ever seen
exclamation point
i don't read uh youtube comments because
i used to read youtube comments all the
time
and and and they they hurt my feelings
so i was like i'll just not do that
again
but neither there's a full-on discussion
about how attractive i am
maybe i'll add maybe i'll get back into
it
you were like would you like to do it
again and that's just something people
say or i thought that was just something
i thought that was your legal obligation
to say that after the show
you're like yeah we'll have to go on any
time next time you're in town
and and then yeah it's just i mean for
me and i'd like to use this
as an opportunity to say this uh
i've been doing this my first date was
2013 was it
december but the chronicle and coding
have been so immensely supportive over
my career like the fact that you know
you did take a small
young comedian from the other side of
the world and you took a risk and you
let them go on stage and
not only did you let me go on tv you let
me do the material that i wanted to do
you really tried your hardest to not
edit it and then everyone backstage
from the from the crew to the camera
crew to
the runners and everything and it's just
a joy to do and then every time i go
back it's just
uh it was something i never expected the
chance to get to do multiple times and
every time i go back it's just such a
i don't know a home away from home and a
pleasure so just thank you so much for
ever allowing me to be part of this
insane
thing it's it's been it's been a
pleasure for all of us and we
love having you and you're part of the
family thanks again for doing this and
uh
everybody can't wait to see you soon i
love you all thank you all very very
much